Чому Україна так настійливо домагається надання їй озброєнь німецького виробництва?
Ідеться, зокрема, про БМП "Мардер", самохідну гаубицю PzH 2000,
танк "Леопард" та зенітну самохідну установку "Гепард".
Ця техніка конче необхідна Україні для другої фази війни з Росією. Пояснюємо чому.
"Гепард" має дві 35-міліметрові гармати і радар пошуку та стеження.
Його спеціалізація - збивати вертольоти і реактивні літаки на низькій висоті.
Співрозмовник DW Міхаель Бухер раніше особисто керував "Гепардом".
Він до 1999 року служив у Бундесвері і добре обізнаний із німецькими системами озброєнь епохи "холодної війни".
Самохідна зенітна установка "Гепард" призначена для захисту як військових об'єктів, так і особового складу.
Це значить, вона стоїть десь на позиції, точніше стояла тоді на позиції і за допомогою радару, що обертається,
"прочісував" повітряний простір, виявляючи літальні апарати на низькій і дуже низькій висоті.
Коли українські військові обороняли Київ від вторгнення РФ, вони часто діяли партизанськими методами.
Розрізненими групами завдавали ударів по російських танках.
Їхньою зброєю були невеликі наплічні протитанкові ракети.
Але тепер військові дії перемістилися на схід та південь України, на великий рівнинний ландшафт.
І в цій битві Україні потрібно більше танків.
Marder - бойова машина піхоти.
У ній достатньо місця для семи стрільців, 20-міліметрова автоматична гармата,
а також керована ракета типу "Мілан" для ураження наземних та повітряних цілей.
Ви можете бачити це в Україні. Життя танка в бою самого по собі коротке.
Навіть бойовому танку завжди потрібні підрозділи підтримки, піхота.
І "Гепард" теж потребує військ десь поблизу.
Його радар дозволяє проводити розвідку повітряного простору.
Якщо наближається ворожий літак, він може надіслати попередження штабу.
Такі речі набули великого значення.
Гаубиця 2000 використовує 155-міліметрову мобільну артилерійську зброю для захисту передових військ з тилу.
Дальність її снарядів - до 56 кілометрів.
З роботою гаубиці Міхаель Бухер також добре знайомий.
Гаубиця може стріляти трохи далі за інші танки.
Таким чином можна підстрахувати одне одного.
Принаймні так було раніше. Бій вівся групами знарядь.
Танк "Леопард" оснащений 120-міліметровою зброєю та розвиває швидкість до 60 кілометрів на годину.
Він забезпечує 48 годин захисту від ядерної, біологічної та хімічної зброї.
Є дві версії "Леопарда" - стара та нова: "Леопард-1" і "Леопард-2".
Це гордість німецького збройного виробництва.
"Леопард" завжди має бути на передовій.
Далі йде "Мардер" із солдатами, які беруть участь у піхотному бою, особливо в міській місцевості.
"Гепард" слід розміщувати трохи далі від фронту, щоб зберегти повітряний простір чистим.
А вогнева міць самохідних гаубиць - на відстані до 40 км.
Тому ви не знайдете їх розгорнутими на передовій.
Військові експерти зазначають, що війна входить у фазу позиційних боїв,
і ця фаза може тривати досить довго. А це на руку українському війську.
По-перше, втрати живої сили та зброї з російського боку такі, що в якийсь момент доведеться шукати вихід за допомогою переговорів.
Друга реальна можливість полягає в тому, що після успішного контрнаступу українських військ
щонайменше якась частина окупованих територій повернеться під контроль Києва.
Після чого Росія спробує вийти із війни. Проблема російської сторони у нестачі кадрів.
Війна не настільки популярна, як хотіло би політичне керівництво в Кремлі.
Добровольців не так багато, як потрібно, а втрати, як і раніше, високі,
попри те, що акцент нині перенесено на Донбас.
Українці продемонстрували, що вони спроможні вкрай успішно оборонятися.
І що в тактиці вони перевершують росіян, що для мене стало, чесно кажучи, несподіванкою.
Початкові помилки російської сторони були обумовлені помилковою оцінкою ситуації -
вона очікувала, що не буде такого єдиного національного опору.
Це помилкове судження йшло від політичного керівництва у Москві.
Ці помилки продовжилися у військовій ієрархії, де, схоже, були не готові до високо інтенсивних і вкрай складних боїв,
і тому були змушені зазнати серйозних втрат поблизу Києва і навіть відступити.
У новій фазі війни українським збройним силам просто необхідні німецькі системи озброєння,
розроблені спеціально для артилерійських боїв та протиповітряної оборони.
Адже це саме те, що тепер потрібно українцям, щоб остаточно відбити вторгнення Росії.